Welcome to the deep dive. So the source is in front of us today. They essentially form this
hidden architecture of mental health diagnosis. Yeah, it's quite a stack of material. Right.
We're pulling from this massive 29 part collection of clinical review notes.
And this is the exact material that counselors and therapists use to, you know,
pass their licensing exams. Oh, absolutely. It's the master key to the diagnostic manual.
Exactly. But for you, the listener, this isn't just test prep. It acts as a secret decoder ring
for understanding human psychology. We're on a mission today to uncover the really fascinating
high stakes rules that clinicians use to categorize human behavior.
And to separate, you know, normal everyday distress from actual life threatening crises.
Right. And then choose the exact right interventions based on that. I promise you,
by the end of this deep dive, you'll understand the hidden fault lines of the human mind.
I think it's important to point out early on, though, that the ultimate goal of these rules,
which can seem really rigid, isn't just to slap a label on someone.
Yeah, people criticize the manual for putting folks into boxes all the time.
They do. Yeah. But looking at these clinical notes, the objective is clearly finding a precise
roadmap. It's about keeping people safe and helping them heal. Treating a symptom without
knowing the underlying structural diagnosis can honestly do a lot more harm than good.
OK, let's unpack this, starting with the engine of fear, the anxiety spectrum.
That's a great place to start. Because the clinical definition of anxiety isn't just like
a generalized feeling of being nervous. The manual actually categorizes anxiety disorders
based on the target of the fear. Right. The specific vector.
Exactly. So think of anxiety like a blaring security alarm. The clinician's job isn't just
to, you know, turn off the alarm. They have to figure out which window the burglar is
supposedly breaking through. Oh, I love that analogy. Because if the fear is pointed outward
at everything, like a persistent hum about work, health, family, and it lasts for over six months,
that's generalized anxiety disorder or G.A.D. But if the vector is pointed entirely inward
at the physical sensation of the anxiety itself, that changes it, right? It changes completely.
That's panic disorder. The person is terrified of the physical surge of the next attack.
And then there's agoraphobia, which I feel like is super misunderstood.
The assumption is just, oh, they're afraid of leaving the house.
Right. The shut in stereotype. But the clinical criteria say the fear is specifically about
being trapped in a situation where escape is difficult or where help is unavailable
if they have a panic attack. So it's the fear of being trapped without help.
Exactly. Whereas social anxiety disorder, you might see the same avoidance behaviors,
like skipping a crowded party. But the motive is rooted in the feel of being judged.
The fear of negative evaluation.
Yes. And the intervention changes entirely based on that motive. You can't treat the fear of
being trapped with the same cognitive restructuring you'd use for the fear of social scrutiny.
Wow. Yeah, that makes total sense. But the danger of misidentifying this stuff gets
literally life or death when we move to mood disorders.
It really does. The bipolar trap.
Right. The notes show that the most consequential distinction is separating unipolar depression
from bipolar depression. Because clinically, in the room, they look identical. The patient is
profoundly sad, lethargic, maybe having suicidal ideation.
And what's fascinating here is how patients unintentionally hide the most crucial data from
the clinician. Because they don't complain about the highs, right?
Exactly. People do not book therapy appointments because two years ago,
they spent three weeks feeling super energized, hyper productive, and sleeping two hours a night.
Right. They seek help when that wave crashes.
Exactly. But if the clinician only treats that crash, they risk causing a severe psychiatric
emergency. Wait, really? By just giving them an antidepressant?
Yes. Administering a standard SSRI, a selective serotonin reuptake inhibitor to a bipolar brain,
can actually trigger a manic episode. Oh, wow.
Because antidepressants alter neurotransmitters like serotonin, right? In a unipolar depressive
brain that restores the baseline. But in a bipolar brain, if you don't have a mood stabilizer
to anchor the circuitry, that sudden influx of serotonin is basically a catalyst.
It just launches them straight up. It propels them right out of depression into full-blown mania.
Reckless behavior, psychosis, severe impulsivity. It's incredibly dangerous.
So the clinician has to aggressively hunt for that history of mania.
Always. You always have to ask about the highs.
Okay, so moving from the targets of our emotions,
let's talk about the invisible clocks governing the mind.
The diagnostic manual relies so heavily on the calendar to change the reality of a diagnosis.
Timelines are everything in the manual.
Take trauma responses. A patient has a severe trauma. They have flashbacks, hypervigilance.
If that's happening within three days to one month after the event, it's acute stress disorder.
Right.
But the exact same symptoms past the one month mark magically become post-traumatic stress
disorder, PTSD. Wait, does the human brain actually know what a month is?
Why does crossing day 30 magically change the name of the disease?
Well, if we connect this to the bigger picture, it's not that the brain has a literal calendar.
Those timelines represent the brain's natural healing window.
The first 30 days, the brain is in an evolutionary survival mode.
The amygdala is blaring. The hippocampus is struggling to file the memory.
That acute distress is a biological response that needs time to process naturally.
So crossing the 30 day mark means the natural process failed?
Yes. The alarm got stuck in the on position. It goes from an acute state to a chronic one,
which requires a completely different level of intervention, like trauma focused therapy.
And psychosis is sorted by a stopwatch too, right?
The notes talk about this psychosis ladder.
Very much so. Under one month with a full recovery is brief psychotic disorder.
One to six months is schizophrenia disorder.
Right. And anything persisting past six months converts to schizophrenia.
It indicates how deeply entrenched the structural or neurochemical issue is.
The clinician also has to figure out how psychosis interacts with mood.
This part was wild. The difference between schizoaffective disorder and a mood
disorder with psychotic features. Yes. The standalone test.
Right. The clinician has to ask,
does the psychosis ever stand alone for two straight weeks without a mood episode?
If someone has delusions for two weeks while their mood is totally stable, it's schizoaffective.
But if the psychosis only shows up during the deepest depression or highest mania,
it's a mood disorder with psychotic features.
It's just so precise. Okay. Here's where it gets really interesting.
What happens when these mental timelines and distress manifest in the physical body?
Like with substance withdrawals. The contrast here is brutal, honestly.
The physiological realities are huge. Because society thinks of withdrawal
based on movies about opioids. Agonizing, sweating, nausea, intense cravings, which,
you know, is terrible. But the clinical notes are explicit. Opioid withdrawal rarely kills you.
It feels like death, but it's not. Alcohol and sedative withdrawal,
on the other hand, carry a massive mortality risk.
Because of how it impacts the nervous system. Exactly.
Alcohol acts as a central nervous system depressant.
It enhances GABA, which puts the brakes on your neurological activity,
and it suppresses glutamate, which is your excitatory neurotransmitter.
So if a heavy drinker just suddenly stops cold turkey.
The brain is suddenly flooded with glutamate, but it doesn't have
the protective dampening effect of the GABA anymore. It's a massive electrical storm.
Which causes fatal seizures.
And delirium tremens, yeah. It's why clinicians use benzodiazepines as a
first-line treatment there to artificially manage the nervous system so they don't basically short
circuit. And that untangling of physical and psychological leads to delirium versus dementia.
Which is a crucial medical rollout.
Dementia, like Alzheimer's, is a gradual, progressive decline over years.
But delirium is an acute, fluctuating medical emergency that happens in hours or days.
Like a severe impairment in attention.
The nose gave the example of a urinary tract infection in an
elderly patient causing profound delirium that mimics sudden psychosis.
And that's why medical rule-outs are mandatory before starting therapy.
You cannot treat a thyroid problem, or delirium from a UTI, with talk therapy.
Yeah, you need antibiotics, not a coping strategy.
But what about when physical symptoms aren't a medical crisis?
When people are actively faking it? The manual splits somatic deceptions into
two camps based entirely on motive, factitious disorder and malingering.
Right, the motive is everything. Both involve faking symptoms,
but malingering is for external gain, faking a back injury for workers' comp, or avoiding work.
So malingering is basically just a scam.
Legally and clinically, yes, it's actually not classified as a mental disorder.
But factitious disorder, which used to be munchausens, is driven by an internal motive.
They want to occupy the sick role.
Yes. There's no financial reward.
They might alter medical records or actually induce physical harm on themselves
just to get care and validation.
It's a tragic psychological hunger for care. That is so dark.
It's a severe pathology, for sure. Untangling motives is hard enough,
but differentiating deeply ingrained personality from acute episodes is even harder.
Right, we're diving into the personality matrix now,
like borderline personality disorder versus bipolar disorder.
A classic diagnostic challenge.
In the room, they look identical. Unstable emotions, extreme reactivity.
But the separator is tempo and trigger, right?
Precisely. Borderline shifts happen in minutes or hours,
and they are almost always triggered by interpersonal relationships,
specifically the fear of abandonment or rejection.
So a minor argument with a friend can make the emotional floor drop out instantly?
Yes. But bipolar episodes last for days or weeks.
They operate on an internal biological rhythm, not a relationship rupture.
Okay, that brings up OCD versus OCPD.
Obsessive compulsive disorder is an anxiety disorder.
That person has intrusive thoughts, they do rituals, and it's egotistonic.
Meaning the person hates their intrusive thoughts.
They feel tortured by the compulsion.
Right. But obsessive compulsive personality disorder, OCPD, is egosyntonic.
The rigid perfectionist genuinely believes their way is the absolute correct way to do things.
They don't suffer from unwanted rituals.
They just have an uncompromising need for ultimate control.
So if OCPE people think they are doing everything perfectly right,
how do they ever end up in a therapist's office?
Usually because of an ultimatum.
A spouse threatens divorce over their rigid household rules.
Or a boss mandates counseling because they can't delegate and it's ruining the team.
Oh, that makes sense. It's the people around them who are distressed.
Which, you know, this raises an important question
about how distress actually defines illness in the manual.
Yeah, distress is the fundamental dividing line, even with addictions.
Gambling is the only officially recognized behavioral addiction in the manual
because it hijacks the same reward circuitry as substances and causes severe impairment.
And that standard of distress applies to gender identity, too.
Right. The notes state unequivocally that being transgender is not a pathology.
The diagnosis of gender dysphoria is about the severe distress caused by the incongruence
between their experienced gender and assigned sex at birth.
The clinical goal is to alleviate the dysphoria, the distress,
not to pathologize the identity itself.
Same with paraphilias, those atypical sexual interests.
Just having an atypical interest isn't a disorder.
It only crosses the line if it causes significant distress to the self
or if it involves harm to non-consenting people.
Exactly. The pathology is located in the harm and the distress.
So what does this all mean when the distress turns into an acute threat?
Let's talk about the high-stakes rule books, crisis, ethics, and the clinical snapshot.
This is where intuition has to be replaced by evidence-based protocols.
Take suicide assessment. The old way was having clients sign a no-suicide contract.
Which are completely useless and not evidence-based.
Right. Asking someone whose brain is depleted by depression
to just rely on willpower to honor a contract, it offers zero protection.
It basically just functions as a liability shield for the clinic.
Modern practice uses collaborative safety planning, like the CSSRS scale.
You assess ideation, plan, intent, access to lethal means,
and protective factors in that exact order.
It's about building cognitive off-ramps, not demanding compliance.
And when the threat of violence is directed outward,
we have to look at the Tarasoff rule, the duty to warn.
Because confidentiality is the default, obviously.
It's the bedrock of therapy.
But it breaks if there is a serious, imminent threat to a reasonably identifiable victim.
The threshold is super specific.
Venting vague anger-like, saying,
I hate everyone at this job, doesn't cut it.
Right. It's not enough to breach confidentiality.
They have to name a specific person, have a plausible plan, and the means to execute it.
That's when you have to notify law enforcement and try to warn the victim.
And then there's mandated reporting for child or elder abuse.
In ethics, the boring answer is usually the right one.
The standard is reasonable suspicion.
You don't investigate yourself as a therapist.
Never. You don't call the family to verify claims.
Doing that can tip off an abuser and put the client in immediate danger.
You report the suspicion, you consult, you document,
and you let the trained state investigators do their job.
Okay, so to document all of this in a crisis,
clinicians use the mental status exam, the MSE.
It's a clinical snapshot of right now.
Yes. Stripping away history and just looking at the present state.
And here's where the climate and weather analogy comes in, which is so helpful.
The MSE forces clinicians to separate mood from affect.
Mood is the climate, what the client tells you they feel like I'm devastated.
And affect is the weather.
It's what you objectively observe on their face, their vocal tone, their body language.
So what does this all mean in practice?
It means it would be incredibly eerie to see a client with a self-reported,
devastated mood, but a bright, smiling, incongruent affect.
That mismatches massive diagnostic data.
It could mean severe dissociation or a manic state masking as depression.
You also have to separate thought process from thought content.
Thought process is the flow of thinking.
Is it logical? Tangential? Racing?
And thought content is the actual substance.
Are there delusions? Suicidal ideation?
Because someone could sit perfectly calmly with a totally linear thought process,
speaking in great paragraphs while explaining their absolute conviction
that federal agents are talking to them through streetlights.
Exactly.
Intact process.
Totally disturbed content.
Or they could be talking about a mundane trip to the grocery store,
but their process is completely derailed by word salad and it's unintelligible.
Wow.
The architecture of clinical diagnosis is just staggering.
We've mapped how the vector of a fear separates anxiety disorders.
We've looked at 30-day trauma boundaries,
the internal motives of factitious illness versus malingering.
It really highlights how much goes into this.
And honestly, this knowledge makes you as a listener infinitely more empathetic and observant.
For sure.
You now know to look for the climate versus weather in your friends.
Or you can understand that a colleague's rigid perfectionism might actually be egosyntonic,
which totally changes how you interact with them.
It fundamentally changes how you view human struggle,
which actually leaves me with a final, somewhat provocative thought to mull over.
Oh, let's hear it.
So the sources mention the criteria for prolonged grief disorder, right?
And it specifically says that the prolonged grief has to be weighed
against the individual's cultural norms.
Yes, the cultural context matters.
And similarly, ADHD requires symptoms to be present in multiple environments,
like struggling to focus at home,
but also struggling to remain perfectly seated at a desk in a classroom.
Right.
Well, if diagnoses depend so heavily on the culture we happen to live in,
or the highly artificial environments we are forced to perform in,
it raises a huge question.
How much of mental illness is actually a fixed biological flaw within the individual?
And how much is simply a mismatch between a purposely normal human brain
and a modern society that demands a very specific,
totally unnatural type of productivity?
That is a fascinating question.
It really shifts the lens on what we call pathology.
Exactly.
Something for you to explore on your own.
Keep analyzing the mechanisms behind the behavior.
Thanks for joining us on this Deep Dive.